well hey everybody what's going on
hopefully I was just checking to see if
the damn [__] was on what are you doing
it's all [__] up well yeah that's what
that's what happens well no now you're
cutting my head off why you f here just
don't don't when you she she want to
complain well why are you [__] with
it cuz I fixed it before I I do what I
do I had it I had it I'm trying to get
it so we're in screen okay see so we're
the same see so we the same so what the
say you're trying to make it different
there you go that's how that's how I had
it before that's how you had it before
no wrong moved it that it's wrong it's
like that then now we're in
there Tom can't ever just leave it alone
he has to like [__] with it he got to
[__] with it it's technical difficulties
what yeah what else technical it's
technical yeah yeah this a pretty good
movie yeah now you would never seen this
I had seen it before but I was actually
surprised that um that we hadn't
reviewed it at any point because I love
Anthology movies and I especially love
like Amicus ones yeah and um anything
that has Peter kosing in it Christopher
Lee ingred pit yeah hubba hubba yeah so
uh so yeah this is like a really good
one yeah so this came out in
1971 and I think this was the third
Amicus Anthology right I think the first
one was maybe or there were two before
this one I think it was Dr Terra House
of Horrors and I think one called uh
torture
Garden but this was the third one and I
this might be my favorite of all of them
I don't know Tales from the Crypt was
good too which I think came out a year
after this but um I don't know there's
just something about this one that I
always really liked I remember the
poster from this they were always
showing it like in uh uh fangoria
magazines when I was a little kid yeah
you know uh the wax uh the wax figure of
the woman with the head the head on the
platter and she's got a skull yeah her
head's like you can see a skull coming
through her face remember seeing that as
a kid and I had no idea what it was
talking about I didn't know was about
this movie I just remember that image it
is a very iconic image yeah it was like
uh it freak you out when you were you
know like five or six
seven yeah that's right I was reading
that [__] we were getting our hands on
it at that young just buy it at the buy
it at the damn store my cousin Wesley
used to buy all
that and I will note too that the image
on the poster does actually happen in
the movie although there's no blood in
the movie though which is very funny
because the movie is called the house
that dripped blood never seen any blood
yeah uh yeah I don't think there's any
blood in the movie uh for his part I
believe the director who was Peter
duffel uh they actually wanted Freddy
Francis who you know did a lot of these
and he did ACH bunch of hammer movies
too but I guess he like wasn't available
so Peter duffel did it he wanted to call
the movie evidently death and the Maiden
because that was the name of the piece
of music that he used in it it's piece
of classical music I think it's uh
Frederick chopan but um but the
producers were like no we can't call it
that we have to call it something lurid
so they called it the house that drip
blood and uh so even though but like I
said so this is a very non
gory uh thing you know what Ian it's not
that kind of movie it's not yeah not
really not really it's and it's kind of
like I am going to say like a lot of the
Amicus um anthologies they kind of used
EC Comics like as um you know as kind of
like a framework yeah so a lot of the
stories would be like people doing bad
[__] and like getting their comeuppence
yeah which this one kind of has that but
not to the same degree I think because
if you if you look at something like
Tales from the Crypt which I think I
reviewed last
Christmas um that one has a lot more of
an EC Comics bad people getting their
Just Desserts kind of thing it most of
the time this one I kind of feel like
some of the characters do bad [__] and
get punished for it but not this one is
a little bit more ambiguous in that
regard so all of the stories were based
on stories by Robert block who you know
obviously wrote Psycho among many other
things and he adapted all of them for
the screen now some of them are better
than others I kind of feel like the last
segment which stars John Pertwee uh or
the Third Doctor Who Um was like you
could tell that that was intended to be
like a horror comedy and I think
originally the whole thing was supposed
to be more comedic but the producers
didn't really like that either they
wanted to make more of like a straightup
horror film so I think they took some of
the comedy out of the the fourth um
segment but a lot of it is still in
there so I think the fourth one I do
like the fourth one but it's tonally a
little bit different than the other ones
I feel like you know what I'm saying
yeah so so supposed to be kind of like
Tales
mcrypt right right right yeah I mean
that was show that was the impression
that I got anyway where it was supposed
to be like funny yeah but the first
three stories are not funny but the
third one is just kind of funny and the
third and the or the fourth one is kind
of funny but the fourth one also kind of
like ties in with the frame story as
well yeah there was a comic book me and
Wes used to get all the time when I was
a little kid there were two of them one
of was called creepy and the other one
was called Eerie yeah and they were just
[__] weird and this does kind of
remind me of the stories that were in
there they were an more like animated
little novels yeah little series and
this is heavy metal was out too it was
another magazine but we were look we
were looking at creepy and Eerie what
was it Uncle Eerie and cousin creepy
yeah I think that's and wasn't there a
witch
too I thought there was that was just
the name that was just the name of the
the magazine um yeah yeah uh mascots you
never saw them though each cover had a
different theme they like animated like
or they illustrated The Story Each comic
had maybe four or five stories in it
they were big they weren't the size of a
DC or a Marvel comic book they were
bigger from what I remember yeah they're
the size of a real
magazine pretty good yeah Sebastian said
is this the one with John per as a
vampire yes it is yes it is uh he
doesn't start out as a vampire but he
gets turned into one like later on but
uh but yeah somebody mentioned Dan
helliot is in this as well this is
really like a a star studded cast like
of all and I think that was kind of well
that was something that Amicus did it's
like I don't think because they were
much smaller than hammer they couldn't
really afford to hire Peter Cushing or
Christopher Lee or something for like a
whole movie so what they would do is is
they'd be like hey why don't you come
here for like one day or two days or
something and shoot like a short film
and then they'll put them together you
know what I mean so they were actually
able to get like a lot bigger stars that
way because they didn't have to pay like
a huge the full rate like fee to get
like yeah cuz they' only be on set for
like a day or two I have to say I think
that the segment with Christopher Lee in
it which is the third segment which is
called sweets to the Sweet pretty sure
that's my favorite one and I think you
know just looking at other reviews of
this um that seems to be overwhelmingly
the favorite yeah the witch one yeah
well I like that one because you don't I
mean Christopher Lee is playing a
character who I mean this is you know
there's going to be spoilers in this
obviously because this movie's from
older than I am so which is pretty old
so you kind of get a thing where he's
set up as like a villain like he's set
up as like an abusive dad you know what
I mean like he moves into this house
with his little daughter and she's
adorable and he's a real dick and he
seems like she's not allowed to have any
toys and she's not allowed to go to
school and like all this other kind of
[__] and like he hires this woman to
tutor her and like be a nanny type thing
essentially and um so this woman is just
like horrified that he won't let her go
outside and he won't let her be a normal
kid essentially and um but as The Story
Goes On you learn that Christopher Lee
is actually afraid of this child yeah
the kid's a witch and it turns out that
he has good reason to be yeah the kid
the kid's mom was a witch yeah yeah and
it's implied he killed her didn't he um
they just say that she died but he does
say that he's glad that she died yeah
and at which point and this is before
you know any of this stuff so it's just
like oh it's like oh I was glad that she
died because that was when I found out
that like what she really was and like
the nanny is just like what the [__]
yeah she doesn't believe it right yeah
yeah yeah she starts seeing what the kid
can do right right right kid's Got U
witch powers witch abilities like a
Sith pretty much yeah I mean the kid and
that that actress that plays Jane the
little girl she was in a couple of other
um movies too [__] man she was in she
was in one of the other anthologies I
remember but she was in a couple of oh
and she was in um whoever slew Annie R
as well which I which I reviewed last
Christmas but um yeah so she was in a
couple horror movies and she's great
because she looks so cute and innocent
and everything and then at the end she's
just you find out she's just like
totally evil even though you know she
seems like totally adorable like through
the whole thing and you're like a how
can I B be mean to that little girl like
that and [__] like that and then at the
end you're like oh [__] she the wax
museum one was good though uh they were
all good yeah they're all pretty good
they're all good yeah so the wrap around
of this um the ti
house that dripped blood it's just this
house um I think they actually shot it
on shepher it was shepperton Studios but
that was like the gate house and they
just like kind of goth it out you know
what I mean so uh so yeah so they shot
it at at that house so the wraparound is
that from this house this actor who is
played by John Perle but you don't know
that until later um had been renting
this house while he was working on a
movie and he disappeared
and so this investigator is trying to
figure out what happened to him so when
he goes to the police the cop that he
talks to is all like oh well you know
all kind of weird [__] has happened at
that house over the years like all of
these previous tenants like had all this
weird [__] happened so then you get like
the first couple stories where the cop
is telling the investigator or the um
yeah the cop is telling the guy like
what uh what happened to like these
other people and then like he goes to I
think he goes to the real estate agent
too like right before the last one whose
name is stoker which I thought was kind
of funny because the last one is a
vampire story so he's the one that tells
him about like what happened to the um
the actor that disappeared who like I
said is John per we who spoiler alert he
got turned into a vampire by anger pit
but yeah so that's like the wound and
then the first story is the one with
denholm Elliott in it and he's like a
horror writer right and he rents this
house with his wife cuz he's got to work
on his new book and he decides that this
new book is going to be about like a
serial killer essentially like a
psychopath and he names this character
Dominic and he like draws pictures of
him and [__] like that and as The Story
Goes On he starts to see Dominic for
real like or so it would seem but
apparently like his wife doesn't see him
and all this other stuff so the writer
starts to think that maybe it's like a
dark half situation dark right like
where he just conjured this character
like out of his imagination but it
somehow came to life so it's kind of
like that um or also there's an
implication early on too that he's doing
the [__] but he's like projecting it
onto a fictional character you know what
I'm saying so there's some of that too
because there's a scene there's a scene
where um this Dominic person is
supposedly comes in the house and is
strangling the dude's wife and then he
comes in like he hears her screaming or
whatever like the writer comes in and
he's like what happened and she's like
uh you know was it Dominic I saw him and
she's like no it was you strangling me
it was you you know what I mean so
there's implication that he's using
Dominic as like a like an imaginary
thing that he can that he's acting like
that so he goes to a psychiatrist
psychiatrist say that all that other
stuff she gaslighting him yeah well and
that and yeah and actually I had seen
this movie before but I had forgotten
that twist it's actually like a pretty
good twist because I you know I I forgot
it so I when I saw it again I was like
oh yeah that's right cuz I'm sitting
there thinking oh it's he's not real
like Dominic isn't real but it turns out
Dominic is technically not real but the
whole thing was a plot that was cooked
up by the wife the person playing
Dominic is actually her boyfriend like
the dude she's [__] on the side and
once she um once the writer like drawn
this sketch of this dude and like said
yeah I'm going to write a book about
this psychopath she got her boyfriend to
dress up as that and then like appear
and then she pretends she doesn't see
him you know what I mean so she's like
pretty much trying to drive her husband
insane and I think well the original
plan was that cuz it doesn't go
according to plan the original plan was
that she was going to drive her husband
crazy and get him institutionalized and
then take all his money but in a Twist
of a twist it turns out that the
boyfriend actually decides that he's
actually Dominic like he kind of loses
his mind and he just starts killing
everybody including her yeah so um cuz
she was like yeah dude that wasn't the
plan and he's like I don't care I am Dom
you know what I mean so it was that [__]
yeah so it was like a double twist type
of thing which I I had forgotten that as
well it was a good one yeah I actually
like that story I kind like I said I
kind of feel like I read like a sampling
of reviews of this and it does seem like
I said that the third one with
Christopher Lee is like the favorite
pretty much the overwhelming favorite
and a lot of people didn't like the
first one because they thought it was
too slow or they thought it was
predictable or something like that but I
didn't find that at all um I actually
really liked the first one it was
warming up yeah it warm up the show but
it it actually kind of reminded me
actually of a Night Gallery yeah yeah
yeah I mean these yeah these are very
kind of like morality tale type things
like Night Gallery or Twilight Zone or
something like that which was very easy
comics like they did that a
lot like Night Gallery and the other uh
you know Tales from the Crypt and uh
Creep Show you'd like this this is good
this is a good Anthology yeah it's
British style old school British yeah
like I said it's not super lurid it's
not gory or nothing but if you like that
old school kind of [__] but yeah in the
70s man the British were the [__]
best at making these movies they were
[__] well crafted the acting's a
[__] suburb they didn't have bad
British actors they were all good yeah
you really did like I said it was just
everybody was like super classy in this
yeah and they uh good sets and just and
they could do it on on a very small
budget that's why Star Wars was filmed
in England the first Star Wars because
they could get it down little fantasy
films that they did Sinbad and all that
[__] [__] yeah a lot of people don't
realize that but you're basically the
original Star Wars Trilogy of British
movies uh you know Empire Strikes Back
probably one of the best British movies
of all times well yeah yeah yeah so yeah
the first story is called method for
Murder By the way so then the second one
was the one with Peter Cushing in it and
this was also a good one now technically
this one didn't take place in the house
although Peter Cushing's character he
retired and he wanted to go like move
out of the city or whatever so he moves
into this house and then he goes into
the town which I think is in Sur
somewhere and he finds this
wax museum which you know wax museums
are always good settings for horror
movies I find and there's a figure in
there of Salam and she's got you know
she's got the head of John the Baptist
on the tray like like you do and um this
this figure like fascinates him you're
led to believe because it resembles a
woman that he used to be in love with
and is now dead now I don't know if they
ever specify that this is the exact
woman because that would be hell of a
coincidence wouldn't it or if the figure
just kind of looks like whoever you need
it to look like you know what I'm saying
because it's implied that the figure has
some kind of like hypnotic power over
men you know so it could be that she's
like projecting somehow because you find
out later that like the guy that owns
the wax museum that was his wife and he
well he killed right or no she got
executed for
killing she got executed for killing the
boyfriend yeah I can't it was yeah she
was a murderous but see but then I think
you find out later that he actually
killed the boyfriend and like let her
take the fall for it and then let her
get executed so he could just keep her
body forever because he's a [__] free
turns out and he's still alive and he's
still alive and he's like ah so he made
it and then I guess I don't know if this
was like an unintended side effect where
he made this cuz he keeps it behind a
curtain and everything
but he's like every now and then
somebody will come in the wax museum and
be like hey I want to see that [__] and
like he'll pull the curtain aside and
then they're like oh and they become
like hypnotized or like fascinated by it
so like Peter Cushing he comes in there
and sees it and like I said you're led
to believe that it looks like this like
resembled this woman that he was once in
love with like a long time ago who died
and so he keeps coming back and then he
has a friend that comes to visit him and
the friend goes to the museum too and
you find out later that these were kind
of like Rivals for the same woman like
obviously they're friends now but like
cuz it was a long time ago but they were
both Rivals for the same woman they were
both in love with her and the friend
also goes there and gets all [__]
Mooney about it and he gets
so he gets so like entangled in the [__]
that he doesn't even want to leave town
like he's supposed to go back to the
city like go back to work or whatever
but he just can't leave cuz he just
keeps going back to the wax museum and
like staring at it so this one actually
did have some really I mean the wax
figures in this were not great I mean
they were like kind of cheapy ass
looking but other than that I really
liked they did this really great um like
nightmare sequence like Peter Cushing
like has a nightmare where he goes into
the wax museum and he's like walking
toward the the figure of the woman and
the way they shot it they had like these
weird like fishey lenses and like all
this weird like Gallo lighting and all
that other kind of [__] and that was
like really really cool I thought it was
like the best part of the of the thing
yeah Cushing of course he he does his
usual man great actor looking Dapper as
[__] in this thing you know that that
cool dude the [__] Skitty as [__] he
must have weighed 100 pounds I love be
he looked cool man that's one of the
best looking old man yeah had that old
man he so [__] cool looking man he's
always so [__] cool looking we saw
another saw another movie of his a
couple days before this one might have
been no it might have been the same day
wouldn't it shock waves yeah that's
right they're playing shock waves for
free on on um Amazon Prime if you everen
seen that one see it that's a Florida
movie yeah I think we reviewed that one
not too long ago Nazi zombies we
rewatched it like the other night Nazi
Zombies in Florida on a d it's good
Peter Cushing's in It All American cast
it's got the girl from the
dam what was that uh dark uh [__]
know what was the name of
that Stephen King movie Dead Zone got
the girl from the dead zone she's in it
oh yeah yeah that's right she's just
real young in it Brooke Adams Brook
Adams she's she was also in um Invasion
of the Body Snatchers yeah the the
Philip coff from 1978 one but yeah she's
great I love her that's yeah that that
is actually like a really good movie I
think we reviewed that one aged really
well yeah it seemed cheap at the time
that it came out but you seeing it now
it was pretty good shock waves it kind
of stood up to the test of time and
Cushing you know he he does good does a
good role in it he kind of elevates the
movie and uh it's kind of a kind of a
slasher but there isn't much Gore in it
uh people running from these damn
aquatic Nazi zombies and Peter Cushing
was aquatic Nazi zombies if that doesn't
make you want to see it I don't know
what well yeah Peter Cushing was uh some
kind of ship commander and he was he was
transporting them and when they lost the
war he never got any orders what to do
with these things so he Shipwrecked he
sank the ship off the coast of this
island off the goes to Florida and he
just stayed in this abandoned hotel
watching over him and eventually the
zombies got out they were looking for
him pretty good a
flick Allison says Cushing was best in
Tales from the Crypt 1972 yeah that's
right he played man that was a like
really tragic role he played like I
reviewed that movie not too long ago and
he plays like just this really really
nice old man who these like Rich dicks
in his neighborhood are trying to like
get kicked out because he's like a
garbage man or something and he's like
beneath their station and so they do
they they embark on this like campaign
of harassment and Terror like to get him
to leave and he won't and uh it's pretty
sad like the [__] ending is pretty
sad and the thing about it like I'm not
sure because I know that Peter Cushing
was quite famous for um you know his
wife going through that really horrible
terminal illness and he was like trying
to work all during this time and like
trying to take his mind off it um I'm
not sure in this particular
Anthology which was
1971 um you know he did have in his role
he was like kind of um uh pining after
this woman that had died so I always
kind of feel like I don't know if his
wife had died at this point I thought
she had died before he filmed Tales from
the Crypt because I remember reading
that he used a lot of that because he
had a dead wife in that one too and he
like always talked to her picture and
that's why he didn't want to leave the
house was because he thought that her
spirit was still there and he was
communicating with her and I kind of
feel like that that him going through
that like in his real life like really
informed his role in that because man
that is like a really really sad [__]
um performance that he gives in that and
kind of same thing here but that's kind
of what I mean when I was saying that
you know in a lot of these kind of Tales
from the Crypt like e Comics kind of
stories it's usually like shitty people
um getting punished for being shitty
whereas this one
there's not really I mean the thing
about it is that Peter Cushing and his
friend um you know they both were in
love with this woman but it's like it
doesn't they don't imply that they
killed the woman or anything like that
they were just Rivals for her love that
neither of them got her and they're
friends now so everything worked out
okay so I kind of feel like cuz spoiler
alert both of them get beheaded they
both get killed um and their little
heads get put on salam's little tray
there so I'm just kind of like so that's
what I meant because they they are not
bad people either one of them they're
actually like both really good people
and they still get [__] over by this
[__] that runs this wax museum who I
guess gets away Scott free doesn't he he
doesn't die at the end does he the wax
museum guy no no so he gets away with it
which like I said that's very unusual
because EC Comics was usually you know
this villainous person did this terrible
thing but then they get like this you
know kind of um Poetic Justice type of
Fate happened to them at the end but
this one is not like that like these two
guys were like good people but they
still got [__] over at the end cuz
they both got their heads cut off you
know what I mean yeah mango says Helen
Cushing passed away in 1971 okay so yeah
so either she was dying when he was
filming this or she had just died after
he died after she died [__] Peter
said everybody knew Peter said he he
didn't care anymore said he was ready to
go that's so sad to me I mean it's
understandable though they've been
together a long time he said you could
you he kind of lost some energy yeah
after that yeah got depressed yeah well
he still making movies he was still
working oh yeah yeah well like I said I
think I've read an um interview with him
where he's just said well you know he he
wanted to take his mind off it cuz he
like he didn't want to just sit in the
house and like Moon about it cuz you
know so he was trying to work to take
his mind off it and he was just like the
consumate professional you know what I
mean you just kept on going um Allison
says has anyone seen Vault of horror in
1974 I believe yes I have I don't did I
review it I kind of feel like I did
because I remember I watched it again
recently but I can't remember if I
reviewed it or or not if not I might get
around to doing that because like I said
I love love love Anthology movies so
yeah so we already talked about the
third segment which was the Christopher
Le one with the little girl had some
people they T saying that they liked
shock waves if you like shock if you
liked shockwaves I think that was 1977
was it I think it yeah somewhere around
there right if you like that one there's
another one that's kind of like it that
I remembered as a kid and I tracked it
down and find I didn't wasn't sure what
the name was I had the name wrong and we
we re watched it maybe about a year ago
it was good it was called um Death Ship
yeah it's about some people out in the
ocean on a little pleasure boat they run
into this
big um abandoned Ghost Ship floating out
in the in the ocean at night and they
get on it and it's an old SS ship it was
some kind of intelligence ship where
they were torturing people on it for
intelligence and they did uh they had
some other I forgot what I need to see
it again CU I only saw it once as an
adult but the ship is uh haunted that's
pretty good that's pretty good that a
good Death Ship yeah not to be confused
with Ghost Ship which is also good but
it's a completely different it's called
Death Ship and it's from the 70s I
believe or very early 80s yeah that's
right did we do a re review of it I feel
like we did because usually when we
whenever we watch a horror movie we
usually try to review it unless it just
didn't make an impression basically A
Haunted House movie yeah but it's on the
water in this abandon and it's in a real
abandoned ship that they got to film it
you know which that's always got some
very similitude there yeah was all
peeling off of it mango said uh Peter
Cushing lived till the early 90s he also
managed to have a breed of Rose named
after his wife a that's super sweet I
didn't realize he lived that long yeah
he did yeah yeah he did um but yeah so
okay so we already talked about the
third segment which like I said I think
that's probably my favorite if you put a
gun in my head and made me pick one um
because Christopher Lee is always great
I love the ambiguity of you just think
that he's like this horrible
authoritarian like abusive dad and like
this poor little innocent child is like
I'm not allowed to have any toys and
blah blah and you're just like man what
a [__] but then like as it goes on
you're like oh wait a minute maybe maybe
he's not a [__] like maybe that
little girl is [__] evil M said we
did Death Ship yeah I thought we did cuz
yeah I remember watching it like not
that Longo we got a review on there if
you guys want to check it out Death Ship
it's it's back there somewhere in all
the 50 bajillion reviews that we did
yeah um but yeah so so then we have the
fourth and final uh segment which is
called the cloak which is the one with
Doctor Who in it um and this one like I
said is kind of more plays out more like
a comedy Now initially and I no you know
no disrespect respect to John perw but
initially they wanted Vincent Price for
that role um and he wanted to do it but
he was still under contract with AIP
American International production so he
couldn't do it but I kind of feel like I
don't know I think this would have
played better with Vincent Price in that
role but like I said no disrespect to
John per we though but I because he's
good in this but I think it would have
been like a lot cooler like with Vincent
Price in there because then you would
had Peter Cushing Christopher Lee and
Vincent Price in the same [__] movie
and that's always oh that always like
gets me all excited it's hard to believe
that Christopher Lee ended up being in
the Star Wars prequels it is yeah and he
did good remember we did that show about
Christopher Lee and Peter CU God I love
those [__] I love those [__]
yeah they just they just every single
movie there they just [__] classed it
up and like I said they never and Vince
Price was like this too he always seemed
like he was having a blast for one thing
but it's like Christopher Lee Peter
Cushing you paid them to be in your
movie even if it was some shitty like
b-grade zgrade movie or something like
that they just they took that [__]
seriously man we didn't never see the
sequel to Dr fives oh yeah we got to see
that too like we did the first Dr fibes
right yeah and I think it's free I think
it's free on um yeah I think it's on
Amazon Prim I think both of them are on
yeah because we yeah we we just watched
psychedelic comedy horror yeah yeah yeah
weird yeah but yeah so they wanted Vince
and price for the John Perle rooll but
he couldn't do it so um so yeah so what
you have John per plays he's the actor
that disappeared at the beginning that
got this whole Anthology started like in
the frame story so this is what happened
to him so he's this super snotty actor
um you know a horror actor right and
he's been in all these and now he's in
this like
cheesy [__] degrade horror movie and
he's really not happy about it like with
this firsttime director or something
who's like like a third of his age or
something so he's just like not having
it so he's just like super condescending
and St he's just like look at these sets
and it's like they're so cheap and all
of this stuff so they give him he's
supposed to be a vampire and he talks
about there's a great little funny line
in here where he says he's talking about
like uh you know what happened to like
all the classic horror movie he's
talking about the universal classic
horror mov it's like Dracula he's like
oh and I'm talking about the Bella Los
Losi one not this new fella you know
referring to Christopher Lee who was in
the segment just prior which I thought
was very funny so it's like a little in
joke that um and apparently John per we
based his performance on Christopher Lee
as well
although I I don't know I can't really
see that Christopher Lee always came
across as a lot more dignified John pwe
comes across as like a funny
it's it's like over the top you know
what I mean like over the top watching
Christopher Lee makes me want to maybe
get off into the Christopher Lee Dracula
movies I've only seen one of them pretty
good yeah you showed it to me but he
said got a [__] ton of them don't he
yeah yeah yeah I showed you the first
one right I think so yeah 1958 I think
no it was color yeah it was yeah it was
color okay yeah then I think I think I
saw that he wasn't in any black and
white ones okay that's where the uh the
the British hippie chicks the 1960s
looking hippie chicks were in they were
dressed pretty nice weren't they working
in at a strip club one of them oh wait a
minute which one did I show you I was
pretty sure that I showed you the first
one which was 1958 he was in how many
Hammer Dracula movies was eight all
right maybe I might have showed you
Dracula 8 1972 I think maybe that's what
you're so maybe I've shown you two cuz I
know I've shown you the first one
Dracula 801 1972 that was the one with
like the hippies where they woke them up
yeah yeah thepp woke up um but yeah so
there's a bunch of other ones that you
haven't seen yeah that he's now does he
have lines does he actually play a
character or does he just appear and
kill people in some of them yeah yeah
all right in some of them yeah I always
thought he made like such a great but
yeah you know and we've talked about
this before like I I've liked a lot of
actors that play Dracula because
everybody kind of has their own spin on
it because it's you know it's a wide
open character you can kind of do
whatever you want but Christopher Lee to
me always seemed the most physically
imposing yeah the most imposing Dracula
because he's big he's like a big tall
dude and he always seem the most feral
he always seemed like the most
animalistic like he's still almost a
werewolf yeah he's still distinguished
and he's still elegant but he seems like
the physicality is like a lot more than
a lot of the other people that have
played him so cuz I feel like some
people like Bell GOI kind of went the
more Urbane route uh you know which is
that's cool too I like that Bella got
you with mind Powers right yeah so
vampire Mind Tricks but Christopher Lee
like L looked like he would just like
he'd be all swab and [__] and then he'd
just and just like crush your neck like
that the only thing that was wrong with
the original Dracula though is that
there wasn't much action in it and
[__] there wasn't any fighting in it
and and Dracula kind of goes down like a
[__] they just open a box and stab him
you know what I mean there isn't a big
conflict scene the the Spanish Dracula
made it exactly the same time has more
in it it's shot better I mean I will go
to B for that Spanish dra we talked
about that before it's like look I love
bellosi and I love that version of
Dracula but the Spanish Dracula even
though I like bellosi better than the
actor that played him in Spanish Dracula
because he kind of had his own thing but
the Spanish Dracula is uh the shot
compositions are more interesting
there's more the story in it there's
more the vampire Brides there's
more in it like from the book The
Renfield I think is a little better yeah
Renfield I think is a little bit better
the way they uh the Spanish char
character of Dracula he's odd but he's a
little bit more like Max Shrek from nsh
from more than that kind of R um now if
you guys don't know what we're talking
about if you're new to the show if and
maybe you don't know much about these
old movies when they did that original
bill of legosi Dracula at the same
Studio at the same time did a Spanish
version of it yeah like sh they shot it
at night shot it shot it on the off
hours same sets and everything but
different director and a different cast
it's the same script but they edited it
differently and they included a bunch of
stuff in the Spanish Dracula they did
that quite a bit back in the Universal
they would shoot a Spanish version
because it was a big market for yeah the
Spanish version seemed like it was a lot
more expensive movie because the camera
went through the sets so it more 3D you
see how expensive those castle sets were
it wasn't as Spanish dra doing [__] like
walking through spider webs without
breaking them and he had slightly
different more Powers Yeah and um there
seemed to be a little bit more action in
it but I don't know if it was actually
action or if it just made you think
there was more action in it more happens
in it I recommend Spanish Dracula over
the English dracul well I mean you
should see both it's really it's a
really interesting comparison to make
because like I said they were
essentially made at the exact same time
like they were shooting Dracula during
the day and then they would shoot the
Spanish Dracula at night and because
they were going for a more uh Latin
audience it's sexier yeah yeah the women
are
hotter you know yeah and more busty more
yeah uh light uh white skinn black hair
looking vampire brides and the the so
were the uh the human women just more
goth
looking just it was it's it's a superior
movie but bosi makes the first one I
mean well yeah even though I don't want
to I don't want to [__] on that Spanish
dude's version of Dracula he did a good
job as Dracula yeah he's not copying BOS
at all he
it's his totally own take on it if he's
copying anybody it'd be Max Shrek and
yeah maybe not even cuz Max Shrek was
just like a creepy freak you know yeah
and that was a silent movie yeah so but
he delivers it I think kind of the way
he imagined NAS veratu from Max Shrek
like if he could talk and if he could
talk right but um but yeah okay so
speaking of busty ingred pit is in this
and I told Tom early on I was like ingr
P She warned me and I was like remember
uh you know what was it not vampire
lovers uh Daughters of Darkness D
Dracula what the [__] okay I can't
remember now but um but yeah so ingr pit
was in a [__] ton yeah these movies and
uh you know she's known for her uh dual
assets let's call it that so he was
looking for the whole movie is that iner
pit I was like no it's not I was
waitting for show so she's like in the
last she's in the last pit and then like
as soon as she turns up cuz she's the
girlfriend SL co-star actress of John
pwe's character he's playing the vampire
in the movie yeah so as soon as she
turns up she's got that like cigarette
in the holder and the nice cleavage and
Tom's like oo she
is that's juicy
yeah I just like I cracked but he said
that man I love angr actually 60s 7s 80
80s British movies they were they were
the connoisseurs of boobs they
understood boobology they love boob they
like Bo yeah I agree I agree yeah Tom is
totally on board with that he also he
also loves 100% yeah and uh as too but
he really really loves like boobs too
big boobs yeah
yeah but uh now she shows up and um she
looks great and um she's uh we thought
Jenny thought she was po uh German but
she's polish I think is she polish and
German yeah or Austrian or I can't
remember polish and I think I think one
parent was from Poland from German I
love her she has a German accent yeah
germanish sound accent but she was in a
ton of Allison said said I would go gay
for anggry pit in a heartbeat same I
looked it up I
mean in those days she's super hot for a
natural woman there there's no silicone
enhancement there that's all
real she was respectable and the British
knew how to put a put put these women in
the right bras they were [__] busting
out yeah make them look bigger than they
actually were um cuz you know I went and
checked I went I went I went and [__]
did bology see how how big she actually
was yeah Tom had to go had to go see
there's nudes while we were watching the
movie he's like okay we need to we need
to get some information about this yeah
it's not not impressive by today's
standards with likeing implants
everywhere right right right but but for
a natural woman yeah I kind of feel like
like implants are nice and stuff like
that but if somebody's just got like a
nice natural rack you don't have to do
much to it then right it's just like you
know you can appreciate that for what it
is it doesn't have to be like super
silicone or nothing like that we can
enjoy all kinds of boobs then there's
this then there's the those like one in
10,000 chicks that are just like homi
Tanaka and she's probably like a one in
four million in Japan oh yeah he showed
me her porn [__] God yeah she a Japanese
girl yeah with gigantic yeah natural
natural and she's skinny and she pretty
much had to go into porn because
everyone picked on her yeah in Japan
yeah her revenge was [__] you I'm going
make money off of him now but she has oh
my God they're gigantic just Google
Hitomi Tanaka you'll see it's crazy
those are
real um yeah but yeah so I would totally
go gay for ingr pit for Inger pit um
also for Barbara steel especially in
Black Sunday rare love that um Tom would
like Hazel Court oh yeah have I ever
showed you anything with hazel cord in
it okay maybe I should good maybe I
should um but yeah so what happens with
this okay so he's mad because this movie
is just beneath his dignity right and
it's like they give him this cloak and
he's like where where'd you get this
[__] Spirit Halloween he doesn't say
that but obviously it's like she's like
it's really really cheap I'm going to go
get my own cloak because this one
doesn't even look realistic it doesn't
look like I've been laying around in a
coffin for thousands of years or
whatever the [__] so he finds this
business card on the mirror in his
dressing room that's like this costume
shop so he's like oh well I'm going to
go check this [__] out right here so he
goes to it and it's owned by this dude
who's very I mean clearly is a vampire
you know what I mean he he looks like
super pale and skinny and everything
like that so he's just kind of like okay
well I have this I have exactly what you
need matter of fact I have this cloak
and the dude's like oh my God it's like
this is amazing this exactly what I'm
looking for and he sells it to him like
for a very reasonable price so John perw
goes I keep calling them by their
actor's names instead of their character
names but I will so he goes back to the
set and when he tries the cloak on he
notices to his alarm that whenever he
puts the cloak on um his reflection in
the mirror disappears H that's a little
mysterious isn't it so it turns out that
when he puts his cloak on and he's doing
the scene with ingred pit who is also
like I said she's his co-star but she's
also his girlfriend I guess so he's
biting her neck and then he like
actually starts biting her neck and like
draws blood and stuff and she's like
what the [__] bro you know what I mean
she like flips out about it so then he
starts oh my God every time I put this
cloak on it turns me into an actual
vampire and then a couple times because
there's there's still funny [__] in this
because he puts the cloak on and then
like he starts flying you know like or
floating and he's just like what like
what's going on that kind of [__] so
yeah so it's kind of silly in that
regard so he tries to tell ingr pit that
is like look every time I put this
[__] cloak on I turn into a vampire
and she's like what the [__] you're
crazy like that's that's that's insane
but so he puts it on he's like but it
only only works if you do it at midnight
right I think it's like a whole midnight
situation so he puts it on and it
doesn't work like he's like oh you can
still see me in the mirror it's like I'm
not flying and all this other kind of
crap and then she then this one has a
Twist too and then she pulls out this
other cloak cuz he looks and he's like
oh this cloak has like a tag on it so
this was like the cheapy one that they
gave him originally and she's got the
real one on and she puts it on turns out
ingred pit was a real vampire the whole
time yeah and she was just she set up
this whole [__] to turn him into a
vampire because real vampires in the
world really liked his portrayal of
vampires so they want so they wanted him
to be a real one yeah and he's like
upset about this I'd been like okay it
was cool it was it was another cool EP
um you know story I would say it was
along the lines of something out of the
Night Gallery um yeah like it's well
little vampire story yeah it's funny and
it's kind of cheesy yeah but there
tongue and cheek you you know right
right cuz like I said you could tell
that they were originally maybe going
for like more of a horror comedy tone
but I guess they decided because the
other three are like not funny at all
like there's not really any humor in the
other ones they're like very serious so
this one does seem a little bit I'm
going to say it seems a little bit out
of place just because it's funny and the
other ones aren't but I don't know it
that doesn't diminish my enjoyment of it
though although now I'm kind of curious
to go to the alternate universe where
Vincent Price was actually able to be in
this movie because how [__] awesome
would that have been if Vincent Price
was in this like playing a vampire that
got to bite ingred pit and then got bit
by INR pit
oo now I'm just kind of like going off
on like a whole alternate universe
fantasy about it there we
[Laughter]
go um mango says the shop owner in that
scene was played by Jeffrey beden yeah
that's right who played um oh yeah
that's right I saw this brought
up um but I've never seen that show what
is it cat cat wasall cat wasall
something like that in a very popular UK
show yeah I had heard of that but I've
never seen that show because every
single British review that I saw that
brought that up that he so he's like
super famous over there but I didn't
recognize him I've seen a lot of British
TV shows but I hadn't seen that one and
I can't even remember what it's called
right
now uh mango said ingred had amazing
boobs I have pics yeah yeah Tom also
looked up pics while we were cuz like I
said anytime we see an 60s or 7s British
movie yeah that's going to have a horror
movie that has ladies with big tits in
which pretty much all of them do yeah I
get ready then he's yeah he's got his
tablet there and he's like we need to
like we need to Google this [__]
research and see if we can find some
because pretty much 95% of them have
nudes yeah you know that wasn't a big
deal in in in in Britain you know I mean
they they would you know did topless
posters and [__] like that just the way
it was actresses did that in the United
States not so much it was like a big
deal that's like so weird to me I I just
kind of feel like
well well because it's not weird for
dudes to be topless like nobody cares
about that but like the second women are
topless everybody's like like it's some
big I don't know I don't get it I don't
get it yeah like it was a big deal to
see Farah foset topless yeah everybody
like [__] wigged out yeah and she's
not really that
gifted sorry boobly gifted yeah I don't
even think she had a really nice body
really I don't know what why I don't
remember if I ever saw her top I
probably did at some point I just I
don't I don't know why she was a thing
it was just I don't know what it's
interesting because I'm always look at
her down I'm like what did they see in
there in her I'm always kind of curious
about what like whoever you know the it
girl is at whatever moment it just
always kind of seems like why that
person I don't know I mean it's not said
girl I thought of Ed swick she was an IT
girl though but she was cute but for the
time like that was and I don't know if
she was like a mainstream it girl she
was more kind of like countercultural
she was like a
drug I mean she had a beautiful face she
had a beautiful face we should do a show
about Ed Cedric actually we should do a
show about that whole Andy Warhol
Factory kind of because that is
fascinating although that show would
probably be [__] seven hours long
because there's so many little tendrils
like to go off on Ed was famous for
being famous most of the time being
pretty and being
high basically pretty and High pretty
and high and [__] would wear would
wear cool clothes that you take pictures
of nude and semi nude I think she did
nudes if I remember correctly yeah I
think so too other was just kind of
Twiggy well that was very much the style
of the time like you know and I don't
know if that was just all the drugs or
if that was just kind of like drugs and
bad diet the well no I mean I don't know
if that's why everybody suddenly decided
that that was like the look of the time
it was just kind of like the 90s where
everybody like all the models and stuff
like that like all suddenly looked like
all that heroin Chic yeah like everybody
looked like they hadn't eaten in 3 weeks
and was all like [__] pale and [__]
which you know that can look good on
some people I'm not [__] on that
look entirely but it's just kind of like
I don't know started to go the other way
though all of a sudden JLo showed up and
Anna Nicole Smith when she was
shapely I thought Anna Nicole Smith was
[__]
amazing that was that was the beginning
of my appreciation of big fine or thick
yeah it looked good his boob
appreciation yeah no I had boob appre
appr before that it's just that uh you
know I mean it was more inspired by the
80s bimbo look which was the skinny
cokor with huge implants fake tits and
no no ass at all that was that was
really the the
80s look um an Cole Smith came in and
she looked like some chick that came off
a farm all right she looked like some
big farm girl that you were if you
looked at her too long you'd get her
pregnant that's what she look like
that's that's how fertile She was That's
how fertile she was she just look if you
looks too long she'd get pregnant and
and and and you and you'd fail the DNA
test it'd be
yours what would happen [__] I was like
I was like yards away I don't know how
it happened how did that you're the
father they would say on Mory po yeah
that's that's how fertile that she
look see that's yeah Tom's into that
he's he likes big boobs but it has to be
like he likes a big ass and also big
thighs yeah and a waste yeah like a
small waste like he likes papow Pap he's
likes like Russ Meyer yeah kind of [__]
he likes that kind of stuff yeah I do
you know Jenny knows I have varant
variance you know variations you know I
like the I like the human physique and I
just got different standards for the way
I think women should look and the way
guys should look you know what I mean
but with women it's more of a sexual
attraction of course you know fing I
mean you do have like kind of a wide
band I've noticed because some of the
stuff like he'll show me stuff like on
Instagram or something like that yeah go
look at that yeah yeah and it's like so
he does find like different stuff
interesting but generally his type
is big ass boobs big ass big thighs yeah
you know what I mean like small waist or
muscular yeah but you have to have big
tits though he's not the only the only
body type he said the only type I'm not
really into is like just like skinny and
flat yeah if you're skinny and flat
you're Twiggy no yeah he doesn't like
that but other than that he's pretty
open yeah if you're skinny and you have
big stupid implants you're probably back
in the
running then like just like are way too
big for you and like your top
like all right all right there's like an
element of novelty in Dragon too it's
like fetish yeah he does have like a
thing where it's just kind of like where
some [__] like he'll show me some [__]
it's like look at this woman's boobs and
they're just like and I'm just like how
the [__] does that woman even walk or
sleep or anything and he's just like
yeah but that's cool though like he he
just likes anything that's just out out
of outrageous or like over the top kind
of yeah thank you very much mango gave
us a Super Chat thanks mango ingred was
great in Where Eagles Dare also very
amazing and count as Dracula oh that's
right we might have reviewed that one
maybe that was the one I thinking of a
forgotten Hammer classic yeah yeah I
don't I don't remember it we might have
reviewed that one got go back I got to
see all the old British Dracula ones uh
yeah I'm sure they're all around there
somewhere but yeah we should we should
do them like in order yeah that would be
awesome actually do some kind of
marathon I heard they're not all good
they're all worth watching I will say
that cuz I've seen them all like over
the years but you know some of them have
been better than others um honestly I
like the first one the best the 1958 one
but they're all worth watching that
hammer I think it was Hammer that did
Carmela I like that one with the lesbian
vampires yeah yeah yeah that was a good
one that's been adopted lots of times
because holy [__] lesbian vampires and
that [__] and that uh Sheran lefanu that
came out before Bram Stoker's Dracula
many years before actually the book yeah
yeah the book did it's a novela
technically yeah well you you didn't see
the British version of Carmella man see
it's good yeah I mean like I said
there's there's a lot of different
versions of it but yeah that version of
it is really good I really like it what
what is that version called um well
there's okay hold on there's been a lot
of versions of it was Heavy art called
Carmela okay no that one was the one I
remember was called Carmela I believe
yeah there is yeah there are some that
are called that but there's a lot of
ones that are just Loosely based on it
that they're like lesbian vampires [__]
yeah we're going to make that into and
they're hot too because how could you
lose yeah and then they got the old
young action going on old
older hot lesbian
Vamp chasing after younger hot [__]
mortal women and trying to flip them
into vampires see see dudes love that
[__] [__] right I think girls like it
though love love that [__]
too I also love that [__] well Interview
with the Vampire was just another
adaptation of that was a woman
fantasizing about male vampires doing
that to each other same thing yeah which
is also hot I I also like that um you
know what I mean I'm I'm I'm again very
open uh Leslie says Captain Kronos is a
forgotten one too I've been wanting to
do the captain Kronos movies for a long
time yeah I think there were two of them
but um it's a Dracula movie is it kind
well yeah it's a vampire they they just
didn't have the license so they had to
make another one yeah so it you know so
I I eventually do want to get around to
do it then there was
yorga yeah I want to do those as well I
want to do those as well like yeah what
was that called yorga the count yorga
yeah I want to do those was that Peter
cushion no that was Christopher Lee went
calor oh [__] I know I can't remember no
I don't think so was it I don't know
[__] now I'm getting confused now I'm
getting confused I got to get I got to
go to the dollar store you got to go to
the Dollar Store yeah get some ant
assets man drinking oh you're out yeah I
ran out drinking that damn orange juice
right there I'm G to start belching up
fire yeah get that get that on the live
stream that'd be something yeah Lynwood
SL said don't forget big boobs on a five
five woman are amazing oh yeah yeah the
short
yeah Tom likes short well I'm pretty
short I'm only what am I 5 foot2 I'm
about 5
foot2 um it makes him look bigger
yeah well just more he likes short girls
with big tits a big ass yeah it's just
it's going to be more likely he likes
tall ones too but it's like because I've
seen him like tall ones too but it if
you're gonna be tall you're gonna have
to be if if it's a tall girl like I saw
a girl who was she came in and she was
in her whole English equestrian riding
outfit and everything I asked her
[__] you know she was riding Hunter
and she goes no I'm doing D we talked a
little bit she's probably about 25 she
was 6 feet tall yeah and she was SI but
she was like an Amazon yeah you know
what I mean uh big old
blonde uh and I was saying if you're
gonna be tall you better be in
Amazon yeah you know what I mean I don't
like that tall and skinny you know yeah
I get it yeah like that supermodel look
there's just nothing to it yeah time
doesn't like that I don't like it I
there's nothing there there's no shape
yeah he wants a big old ass he want a
big old ass he can or muscular kind of
body you know yeah yeah shape shape
Lynwood knows what I'm talking about
brother understands the [__] [__] you
know what I'm talking about yeah women
get sold got sold a lot of women not all
women yeah Jenny didn't fall victim to
it I don't think too bad a lot of women
got sold bill of goods sold a false
image of what guys want through like
Cosmo magazine you know did that guys
wanted these [__] skinny models that
they're looking no those were not the
[__] chicks that guys were looking at
they were looking at the girls in
[__] [__] penous they were looking
at the girls in [__] you know I Club
International magazine and they were
they were voluptuous [__] I said sex
bombs you know I kind of didn't feel bad
about it until I start and this might
sound strange and like
counterintuitive but um I kind of
thought that too until I started looking
at a lot of more porn cuz I'm like if
you look at porn um you'll see like what
dudes are actually looking at and a lot
of those women are big are bigger yeah
they're not like there's some SK there's
some scrawny ones too cuz like kinds
they got all kinds but in a way that's
kind of what's cool about it because
it's like pretty much any body type you
can think of is represented and I'm like
that's pretty cool I like that the big
names in the industry the ones that have
stood the test ofon and have been around
for 20 30 years that have kept
followings over years are
are are voluptuous in good shape they're
working out they're lifting they're
taking stuff they got implants they're
very hourglass big big on the top big on
the bottom they're in good shape now of
course you know some of these young
girls will come in they're like a flash
in the pan and they'll the young other
young guys will be into them for a few
years but then they just kind of Fade
Away most girls aren't in it for longer
than about a year here but you know but
the if you want to see the actual
numbers of what guys are looking at you
want to look at like the legendary porn
stars ones that have been around for a
long long time yeah that are still
making content that still making content
there's there's a reason why older than
I am yeah some of them are in their 60s
and there's a reason why they stood that
test of
time and they don't look anything like
them models off of damn Cosmo or or
[__] fashion runway exactly the
opposite
I mean the well the thing about it is
that it's a different audience yeah like
a supermodels they're not really meant
to be like sex objects really they're
just kind of meant to like show what the
clothes look like yeah and another thing
is is that gay men are picking those
guys those women you know whereas
whereas porn that's kind of yeah that's
kind of more geared towards straight
guys so that's going to be like what
their tastes are yeah you know what I
mean fashion is like that's not really
so much a straight man thing yeah um so
those women are not going to look like
yeah what a straight man would
necessarily like J my favorite one my
favorite performer overall and she's
changed a lot over the years recently
she's getting kind of bizarre looking
but she is getting a little bit better
but she's old now she's my age was Ryan
Conor I liked her throughout he used to
show me her butt like all the time yeah
Ryan Conor I like her and she's an
Amazon I think she's pushing six feet
she's or or may you know maybe five9 you
know she's pretty big if I remember
correctly uh let me see hold on lynw S
said count yorga vampire also known as
the loves of count yorga vampire is a
1970 American vampire horror yeah like I
said yeah yeah yeah there like I said
I'm pretty sure there were two of them
and I've been wanting to do those Danny
Rowling said voluptuous is a better word
than
thick thing is those voluptuous can mean
that there's a lot of fat thit can mean
that there's a lot of muscle on
underneath the fat I don't know I think
both of those words are kind of they
might be the same
interchangeable just depends on you know
it's in the eye of the beholder yeah
Danny ring said double muffin tops is
what I'm into like not really now every
now and then you'll see a fat girl I've
showed her a fat girls they look they
look real good yeah they have to be able
to hold it right way right right right
like he's not averse to you know what
you would maybe call a fat girl but it
depends where the fat is cuz he shown me
like some Instagram models and he's like
and the girl is like pretty hefty but
it's just kind of like she looks good
though because of where the weight is
distributed right yeah right just like
yeah I'm kind of into that it's outside
the Norms your average fat girl does not
built like that right it's it's it's
just good genetics
yeah uh let's see so uh somebody asked
now that we're done with a haunting I
mean we're not but we just stopped it
for a while cuz we still have some
episodes left we just got sick of doing
them cuz they were all they're all kind
of the same yeah but somebody said
should we do another uh TV series now
that we're not doing a haunting anymore
like maybe the strain or that's SK Mel
Toro right yeah um yeah I I haven't seen
it I've been it's on my watch list and I
haven't he mentioned dark angel I think
and yeah and you were just talking about
that the other day yeah I S I saw like
maybe we should rewatch that because
that's one that's kind of forgotten
about littleit to buy though yeah it's
Jessica Alba stars in it and it's uh
isn't it James Cameron James Cameron did
the series yeah I thought it was James
Cameron and uh it's supposed to be real
good but I've only seen like the first
four or five episodes I of feel like
it's a little bit forgotten about the
thing is though you have to get it on uh
it's rare on yeah that's what I'm saying
yeah it's like a hundred bucks to get
that series oh [__] yeah you can't
stream it anymore I don't know has
somebody put it on YouTube sh they
didn't make very many uh maybe I'll look
and see they didn't make very many DVD
sets okay cuz I'm kind of curious to see
it because I remember you talking about
it that you really liked it and now it's
like really hard to get a hold of maybe
somebody put it up on YouTube for yeah
or somebody sent it to us as a gift
we'll do it but I would not expect
anybody to pay as much money as yeah you
might be to find Ed cop that's what I'm
saying it's like if somebody had it and
wanted to like just rip us a copy that
would be nice yeah but it was a Jess a
young Jessica Alba played a genetically
engineered chick that could was like a
superhero and she was a milit
super weapon it was kind of like a kind
of like a
superhero uh
series she rode around on a black Ninja
ZX6 I think it was a ZX6 motorcycle and
she could do stuff you know real
acrobatic Danny rling said there was a
used one on eBay for
$40 it's all the seasons the whole
series apparently okay I mean that might
be worth looking into cuz yeah I just
remember you bringing that up before I
still have to finish um Bates
Motel cuz you know Celtic Angel sent us
Bates Motel yeah we still got to finish
that and I still got to finish it it's
just like I just finished watching the
three episodes of rose red and I was
going to do a scar Salon video on that I
just have to like write it all out and
all that kind of stuff like what I want
to say about it but I just finished
watching that but um but yeah yeah
complete set I've never seen it it's
pretty good from from from the episodes
I saw so
that might be worth it can't do it right
now though well no somebody sends it to
us as a gift we'll do it it' be a while
like until we could get to it because
we'd have to watch the whole thing and
we'd have to like it be weeks before we
can get to it and the thing about it is
that with a series you might want to
talk about each episode individually
yeah you know
because be doing a lot of episodes
that's what I'm saying but like I said
some people are talking about like maybe
you could do like a haunted maybe we
could do it like every now and then
because you know what I mean cuz like
over on my scar Salon thing like I'll do
like I have a thriller the Boris carof
show from 1960s and Night Gallery and
like every now and then like I'll watch
a handful of episodes and just like put
up a review of like you know six
episodes or something like that so I do
that like every now like whenever I have
time to watch them you know what I mean
so we might end up doing something like
that but I have been curious to see that
because that was one that I completely
missed yeah out in the old days and dark
angel I think is a forgotten one yeah
you don't really hear many people
talking about it like not in my
perception anyway so yeah and it might
be kind of it might be kind of a thing
too where cuz remember when we did um
that review of like The Dead Zone series
which I Love Actually it's really good
it's got Anthony Michael Hall in it uh
playing the John Smith character and I
feel like a lot of people don't talk
about it and that's a real shame cuz
that was a good [__] show yeah like I
was surprised at how [__] good that
was um yeah Jo says you could watch Dark
Shadows only
1,225 episodes yeah the story never
moves
forward we have a friend yeah uh our
friend will he is super super into he's
a little bit older than us he's 60 he is
super super into the old Dark Shadows
like every time I see him he's always
telling me like what episode he just
watched I have not seen all of the
episodes I've seen a lot of the old ones
and I even liked the reboot that they
did in the 90s with Ben Cross but um
yeah I don't think i' ever have time in
my whole entire life like to watch every
single episode of that but they are good
and I think they're like easy to get
like pretty much yeah he mentioned it
was that uh Dark Angel was kind of like
uh lefem Nikita yeah it was like lefem
Nikita except she was I remember she was
genetically engineered as some kind of a
an assassin if I remember correctly or
or a scout SL
assassin
and she was just real acrobatic and she
had all these weird senses heightened
senses she said it was like cat DNA but
she didn't know what it was she wasn't
sure what she could do at the point
where I was I think I only got like five
episodes in I don't think she knew what
her abilities
were it was good it was a good series
man if I had if I had cat DNA I'd
probably just like sleep all the time
yeah Danny rling said Bruce Campbell's
93 show The Adventures of Brisco County
Jr was a decent show that goes for cheap
complete that just saying yeah I've been
that's another one I've been wanting to
watch because I love [__] bruze
Gamble and then mango said the dead zone
TV version was really good it was
surprisingly good I got really really
into it we own it actually we bought the
whole box it's really really good and I
think we did a review of it I don't
think we did each episode you know
separately but we talked about like the
whole series and I really feel like more
people should see it mind seeing a
couple more of those yeah I've forgotten
them I have too through sock we could
watch the whole [__] thing they're
talking about Dark Shadows being free on
tub yeah I thought it was like every
single episode holy [__] yeah well
that's that's some more content I could
do for my own channel I would like to
take [__] years and years I got to uh
get down to the store all right he's got
to go to the store yeah and uh so I
guess we're going to wrap it up we got a
little far field but not really he said
she did have feli DNA okay yeah yeah she
was in heat every month and in Universe
joke
okay she's in heat just every month not
every day like a cat I guess that's no
fun but uh but yeah all right so
everybody come back Wednesday night
because we're doing a show Tom will love
this about medieval torture methods okay
yeah I've been wanting to do this one
for a while and it's like it finally won
in the PO familiar woohoo so yeah we're
going to talk about some real [__] up
[__] I also liked uh medieval
Justice how they would settle arguments
and [__] outside of court trial by comat
yeah you can talk you can talk about
that but yeah we're going to talk about
like all the [__] up [__] they uh
invented I believe we got to go back to
that though oh I don't know if a lot of
advantages to that I mean maybe some
serial killers would be but most other
people are just I don't think you should
do that to people but yeah we're going
to get into that on Wednesday night uh
so that should be a fun pretty Grim kind
of show uh but yeah so thanks everybody
for dropping by listen to us talk about
go watch House of drip blood it's really
good um I think you can watch it for
free well we had watched it on Amazon
Prime but I think it was on free so I
don't know if you can access that if you
don't have Amazon Prime or not but yeah
so we watched it free with commercials
but yeah it's if you love Anthology
movies if you love Peter Cushing and if
you love Christopher Lee like who
doesn't um then please go watch it
because it's really good I love Amicus
Anthology so obviously I'm GNA say that
but yeah
so what was I gonna say oh yeah so
thanks for super chats thanks for all
your comments thanks for all the
conversation and we will see you guys
again on Wednesday night good
night